hello everybody very good morning to you
we are live from my hometown of wigan
it's the fourth and final day of our
special coverage looking at the cost of
living crisis and how it's impacting the
good people of wigan today we are at
robin park arena where the wigan
warriors rugby club trains beating heart
of the town we'll chat to the team about
how they're tackling rising prices as
the chancellor warns they'll be tough
months ahead joined here by labour's
lisa nandy the shadow leveling up
secretary and wiggins local mp and in
just a moment i'm going to be speaking
to the leader of the lib dems to ed
davey it is thursday it's the 19th of
may
under pressure growing calls for the
chancellor to take immediate action to
tackle the cost of living crisis as he
warns of difficult months ahead
the next few months
will be tough
but where we can act
we will
a matter of life and death the impact of
storing energy bills on families who
rely on medical equipment at home
if we couldn't
literally afford
to pay those bills then
i don't know what would happen
i'm live from the muffin man bakery to
find out what rising prices means for
wigan's daily bread
we're at the local funfair to ask if it
can ride out the cost of living crisis
it was quite a fun day let me tell you
[Music]
and homewood behind the simon and garf
uncle classic apparently conceived right
here at wigan station
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world as more ukrainians are
evacuated from the mario pole steel
plant another two russian soldiers will
go on trial this morning charged with
war crimes
mental health provision is going to be
rolled out in secondary schools like
this one as part of a new initiative
launching today
[Music]
hello everybody a very good morning a
final final day here at wigan look at
that spectacular sunrise here in my
hometown in the background there you can
see the dw stadium
and you can also see the training ground
where wigan warriors hopefully will be
training ahead of victory
a week on saturday we'll be what what am
i talking about we'll tell you later on
in the programme meantime let's start
with the chancellor facing growing calls
to do more to help ease the cost of
living crisis after inflation hit a
40-year high but at a speech to business
leaders last night he failed to outline
any immediate action more on what he had
to say in just a moment but first this
week i'm in my hometown to find out how
people here are being affected by
soaring prices this morning i'll be
finding out about the impact of the
crisis on sport
on culture
and hospitality let's take a listen to
what the chancellor said to business
leaders last night
the next few months
will be tough
but where we can act
we will i'm proud that under this
government it always pays to work but
right now
we also have a collective responsibility
to help the most vulnerable in our
society
and so as the situation evolves
our response will evolve i have always
been clear we stand ready to do more
we're here as i said at robin park arena
where the wigan warriors train uh
they're in one of the final training
sessions ahead of a game at the weekend
chief exec chris ridlinski is uh here
with us now we chatted to you earlier in
the week didn't we at the local primary
school really important for the club to
be involved in the local community
the community is what we're all about
you know we love loving park arena and
we call it a community stadium uh
all
junior clubs are welcome here all our
fans are welcome here and as you can see
we're a pretty inclusive and diverse
club as well you know we love to to have
a women's team training alongside our
senior team as well it's uh really
inclusive yeah okay
i'm sure we can have a little wander
around and have a look at him as as as
we're chatting we're gonna be chatting
to some of the players these are academy
players it is some of the academy
players so they do the early morning
sessions
get to get the work done before the uh
the senior guys come in a little bit
later
um we obviously have got a famed junior
academy for the players that we produce
but uh it's all about hard work it's all
about honesty and
driving each other these guys here adams
we're chatting uh you've got a game
saturday are we playing haul on saturday
in the super league yeah five o'clock uh
the last game before for the cup final
the following week which is a you know a
huge occasion for the club in the town
so uh at tottenham hotspur i've never
been there before so uh really exciting
fun as well as elastics fine i'm gonna
say it's an okay statement very good
you're in safe hands who are we playing
uh we're playing with huddersfield in
the club finally a very difficult game
a well coached team uh they beat us uh
in the last game uh
we'll probably warm up well yeah i mean
we will probably go in as favorites but
we're not we've told the team to prepare
us underdogs uh it's gonna be a tough
one for us yeah 150th anniversary of the
club
yeah
you know it's
an incredible history
we'll be celebrating that all all
through the year with events and things
and uh it's played a significant role in
many people's lives as you know and uh
yeah i'm i'm thrilled of uh what we've
got planned this year and and now it's
unfolding so what would you say to
people who don't understand how
important rugby league is to return like
wicked well i don't just think it's ruby
league i think it's it's sports as
general in general we spoke the other
day about
how it's an escape from the challenges
and reality of society you know the
football club in the town have done
amazing this year with from the brink of
administration to uh you know to getting
promoted it we're really proud of them
as well and i think for those 18 minutes
or 90 minutes of the weekend to escape
the hurst realities of the cost of
living is is so important to the social
fabric of the time yeah is it okay if we
chat to the player absolutely
i'm sorry to interrupt guys i know
you're busy uh talk to me can i sit on
the edge with you
brilliant no no you used to dance i'll
just sit here what are you trying to say
trying to say i've got a big bottom
just as long as we're clear i'll come
over here and then we can
both chat um together that's really tell
me about playing for wigan
that's good uh it's good to represent
wigan yeah you've been here six years
yeah just show up six years yeah how
important uh because it's difficult for
people who don't understand uh how
important uh rugby league is to return
like and tell me what it was like to
play with reserves yeah i think i think
ruby league is a haul in wigan is
massive i think as
i'm from manchester so around there we
don't really do a bit more football base
yeah yeah of course so it won't come
into a little town wigan
i think it's just it's massive it's like
football over there yeah i just think
everyone
everyone works harder everyone everyone
just loves it the passion the fans it's
smart okay and adam tell me about it
you've been here what four years yeah
four years yeah tell me about what's
your position
uh i'm a half back center four bucks or
anything on battlefield wheels okay
you're a big lad then so tell me about
um what it is like for you to be able to
play for me uh it's really books i'm
from a local town called lee so it's
like
really it's summer rival team it's
really good to play for our local team
so
we'll call back
now down the road and come and put all
your effort into it and stuff so yeah
how important is sport to young people
like you two guys um it's really good
because it keeps you it keeps you out of
the sort of bad stuff and like the top
weekend you go and i drink you don't
really want to do it and
you sort of enjoy yourself on on every
occasion but
it's uh yeah it's really really good
very fun absolutely
no i know that's where the greater
manchester verse from us yeah yeah yeah
you see local knowledge let's watch
those weights adam which you go thanks a
lot guys thank you and that's what jack
i think and zach jefferson
hi guys you are jack jack hi jack tell
me about playing for the team it's good
yeah but uh all right out to the season
we've not lost the game yet so hopefully
carry on that performance all the way
through the season yeah
hi good morning tell me about today
yeah
watching the boys you know it's good oh
that's been frustrating though yeah it's
annoying but um
um
it's my uncle so i've put me out for a
while so how can you train up that i'm
just going to be a wounded soldier i
broke my foot i did nothing exciting it
said fell over and it's really
debilitating isn't it so it must have
been very frustrating for you yeah it's
really annoying especially with all the
labs training through the week and then
playing at the weekend but you know
try to work out get yourself back it's
part of the job so yeah
there's a game at the weekend are you
playing enough oh no
when do you get up for the first time oh
and um hopefully hopefully soon but
whenever i get the chance i'll
definitely take it
yeah i feel like i'm ready to get to go
up there but just have to see what um
head coach says if i get the chance i'll
take football fans i'll let you carry on
training then shouldn't i thanks guys
appreciate it we're around all day so
just come and chat to us whenever
thanks a lot um adam i just want to
wander back up here as we walk past some
of the girls we're going to be catching
up with some of the girls a bit later on
careful as you walk by her but before
all of that i just want to bring in
the leader of the lib dens i'm not sure
where my notes have gone they were on
here
laura if i can grab my notes they were
here i don't know where they've gone
meantime let's bring in sir ed davey who
is joining us now hello to uh thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
um
you heard what the chancellor said uh
yesterday welcome to our hometown of
wigan by the way what did you make of it
i just don't think he's doing anywhere
near enough he doesn't seem to get it
there are millions of families and
pensions who are hurting now
and we've seen a government that's first
of all not done enough and then it's
dithering and delaying
and they've got to do something now
i'm really worried okay that um people
out there are getting more and more
anxious about the future they've heard
that this is going to get worse that we
could be entering a recession
the energy bills will go further in the
autumn
and they have a government that seems
tone deaf
can't hear very well sir ed but we'll
plow on for now i'm sure we can sort
that out uh you want to cut in v8 the
argument is that cutting v80 only
benefits those who earn a lot of money
because they can afford more expensive
stuff and they get a better deal
that's simply not true
as a portion of income it helps people
who are less well off it helps cut
motoring bills it helps cut food bills
it also helps cut the rate of inflation
and it helps small businesses who are
struggling on the high street is exactly
the right thing to do
and we would pay for it by a windfall
tax on the oil and gas companies so we
would deliver a tax cut of 600 pounds to
the average family that's exactly what
is needed it's bold in it
dramatic i'm proud that the liberal
democrats are putting forward a
constructive
positive proposal i just hope the
conservatives listen for once
what's the benefit of doing that rather
than
upgrading benefits
well there's room to do both we've also
argued that there needs to be some
target to help on the less well-off and
on pensioners we've talked about the
warm home discount which is money that
comes directly off people's energy bills
that should have been increased it
should be available to more people and
we've talked about the winter fuel
allowance i mean the government are seen
to be attacking pensioners at the moment
first of all they've reneged on the
election promise of the triple lock
which is costing bench and pensioners
billions of pounds then they failed to
upgrade pension pensions uh by the rate
by the real rate of inflation so
inflation is going up by percent
pensions only going up by three percent
this is a wholesale conservative attack
on pensioners and it's not not right
it's not acceptable
what about we were chatting to the mayor
of greater manchester earlier on in the
week and he was talking about a
universal basic income
good idea
well um the party my party has looked at
that and we're going to
produce our our conclusions there are
quite a few other alternatives and in
the short term of course it couldn't be
introduced in the the short term you
need to look at things like the warm
home discount universal credit the
winter fuel allowance and this v80 tax
cut these are the measures that liberal
democrats want to do
and uh they're the ones we're focusing
in on
talk to me about i think it's gonna be
the 23rd of uh june for the uh next uh
by-election that's what we're being told
not yet confirmed i'm sure that we'll
hear about that later on today hearing
more about a lib
lab packed is that on the cards
uh
absolutely not on the cards and it's not
happening what we're doing in the tifton
hondaton by-election
is talking about issues that matter to
people in that area and they're quite
similar actually to the issues in north
shropshire a by-election where we beat
the conservatives
last december seat the concerted hell
for 200 years and we saw lifelong
conservatives
fed up of boris johnson
feeling taken for granted by the
conservatives switching to the liberal
democrats and they were switching
because of the health service you know
difficulty getting uh appointments with
gp sort of too few gps long waits for
ambulances that are getting delayed
because the conservatives have failed to
manage our ambulances properly and then
the cost of living that really is coming
up in the doorsteps already and there's
a rural dimension to that uh you know
okay
in many rural areas the key thing that
people depend on for heating their homes
is heating oil and lpg these are two
types of heating sources that aren't
regulated by off-gen there's no price
cap on them and the prices for heating
oil and lpg have gone through the roof
so rural households
including rural pensioners people in
rural poverty are really being hit
because the government just ignored them
taking them for granted so liberal
democrats will be talking about health
we'll be talking about the cost of
living and we'll be talking about
farmers who as i raised with the prime
minister yesterday
are absolutely being betrayed by the
conservatives we need the farmers to
help families and pensions with the cost
of living with the cost of putting food
on the table but the conservatives are
making it more difficult for farmers to
play that role
what is i mean we've been here all week
we've been hearing about the livelihoods
and lifestyle of the people here in
wigan and the greater northwest region
why you did really well in in the local
council elections of course why do you
think you don't cut through in regions
like
well
this
think we increasingly are cutting
through i mean in the last 12 months uh
it's been really clear that the liberal
democrats are the main challenges to
conservatives in many parts of the
country we have the by-election victory
in true blue buckinghamshire cheshire
ambition we have the by-election victory
that i talked about a minute ago in
north shropshire and our local election
results across the country from cumbria
to somerset from hull against labor uh
to many other parts of the country they
were the best of any political party so
um i think people are listening to the
liberal democrats we're listening to
them we're listening to their concerns
and i think they like the fact that
there's a party that is taking up their
concerns with with constructive positive
alternatives
the conservatives are just taking them
for granted ignoring them
sorry to interrupt you there sir ed uh
talk to me about what's going on uh with
the culture of the palace of westminster
at the moment 50 odd mps are presently
being investigated one has been arrested
on allegations of rape and yet still
he hasn't had the whip removed should
that happen and also was speaking to
labour yesterday they were saying that
it needs to be a more um rigorous uh
selection process what do you think
i think it is utterly shocking
there are some mps who are behaving
outrageously and wrong and they need to
be punished
uh
your viewers if they behave
in their workplaces
in the way that some mps are behaving
they would lose their jobs and of course
the whip should be removed i it
shouldn't even be a question um now you
know
he can be suspended you know if he's
he didn't either needs to be a due
process i believe in the process of law
but in the meantime during these
investigations the extremely serious
allegations of course the whip should be
uh removed and i can't believe the
conservatives are yet again
dragging their feet when one of their
own has broken the law this is becoming
a theme and maybe it's because the prime
minister
uh breaks the law and lies about it and
gets away with it
it's a prime minister's created a
culture particularly in the conservative
party and this is setting a very bad
example for the country for our young
people the prime minister frankly i you
know okay i've called for him to resign
but i don't believe he's a decent person
he's not a decent person to be the prime
minister of our great country and i
think true patriots
would want him to go so this whole
culture
you know that it rots from the top
sometimes official rots from its head
and if i think if we got rid of the
prime minister it will be a big step
forward and beginning to address some of
these problems
so just to clarify you're suggesting
that it's a culture from the prime
minister
downwards within the conservative party
within the government which means that
some feel allegedly that it's okay to
behave in a what is not a satisfactory
in any way manner for the rest of the
country
i mean individual mps individual people
need to take responsibility for their
wrongdoing um let's be clear
however
if you have a culture from the top
where law breaking is seen to be okay
you'll get people away with it i mean
let me give you another example there's
so many
the home secretary pretty patel was
found guilty of bullying her staff
by the independent advisor on
ministerial standards who recommended
action should be taken
the prime minister refused to act
against his home secretary despite the
fact there'd been an independent inquiry
that she had bullied her staff
she's still in place
and at least the inter independent
advisor minister of standards had the
decency
to resign because the prime minister
failed to follow those recommendations
so this is why i say
uh this conservative prime minister
boris johnson is not fit to lead our
country he breaks the law
he allows his mates to get away with
joining us on the program yeah
sorry sir ed we must leave it there
sorry again to interrupt thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
very much continuing our coverage live
here in wigan we're at the wigan
warriors training ground uh this morning
the gym to be uh more precise and as you
can see some of the academic players are
in early this morning for us we'll be
seeing some of the women training as
well and then the first team will be
joining us a bit later on even um a walk
down memory lane for me when one of the
wigan harriers i used to run for wigan
harriers hundred two hundred first leg
of the relay a very long time ago we'll
be talking to her as well a bit later on
but something that is always on the mind
of many people here in wigan at the
moment is the rising cost of gas
and electricity it's pushed energy
prices to record levels and while some
families have been forced to choose
between heating and eating for others
switching off could be the difference
between life and death katarina has more
open the curtains
so
so show them where your oxygen is
when alex was born his mom was told he
wouldn't live beyond a week
he is now a thriving 16 year old but
needs near constant support
at night an oxygen machine keeps him
alive
during the day a pump provides vital
food water and medicine
just let me swap your feed round please
first
everything is run off batteries and
mains power
bills just go up and up i would probably
say an extra 300 pound a month
um just in
in household bills and things for alex
it's a case of life and death obviously
because he's on his oxygen machine
overnight so
if we couldn't
literally afford
to pay those bills then
i don't know what would happen
this is the stark situation faced by
families with sick and disabled children
at home as energy prices rise they
simply can't unplug it worries me for
the future as to
if things do get worse
how
how will it affect us as a family um
what what do we do kind of thing because
it's all very well and good somebody
coming and saying go and get an extra
job or do this and do that but alex
alone is a full-time job i feel like
it's a constant battle with a child with
a disability
and it never stops
a battle in what sense
sorry that's okay
it's incredibly hard
sorry
much needed respite comes from here this
center was set up by emma and other
local parents it's been entirely built
and funded by the community it's support
at the end of the day and there's not
much of it around
you know at the minute it doesn't do me
any good staying on the outside
all the time
even though i didn't love you very much
these children and their families dearly
need this help
they worry as prices rise and budgets
tighten it will become harder to find
do you have any questions
in wigan
still uh in the training uh gym uh and
i'm honored to have the former champ uh
captain uh from wigan maurice sean is
with us higher
when did you stop uh two years ago now
okay two seasons ago okay and you were
in the final yeah i finished not quite
in a high finished in the grand final
lost to sometimes but um to send helens
yeah anyway it's lovely
yeah but no
finished a great career and really
enjoying myself and didn't quite get the
win but it was a great great 20 years
yeah yeah and just to i mean obviously
joking but said helens is the big rival
isn't it just down the road yeah yeah
just over billings hill so it's um
really really intense rivalry but a lot
of a lot of good friends over there as
well and i think the community's been so
close to each other sometimes there's a
lot of
people in work and and all over the town
as well yeah so you're a bit of
superstar really as far as we're going
to be concerned um maybe maybe a weekend
yeah 20 years though yeah yeah very very
long time lucky enough to have a long
career and um play work with a lot of a
lot of good people so yeah i've i've
been very lucky yeah it's quite a
community might it's very much a
community minded club isn't it uh yeah
very much i think everything we do
within the play side of things and the
people coming watching us it's all about
kind of
entertaining the locals and and a big
part of our team culture has been kind
of played through and a lot of our teams
he's met from people who are from wigan
who grew up in wigan uh local areas so
yeah the community means a lot to the
club and
this place at robin park it's it's
really helped help me but
this is a posh gym yeah very posh very
posh it's um i think we've been here now
for three or four years
it's um it's grown value to it it's just
been a brilliant facility not just for
us as a club but i think for people
outside coming in and using it as well
it's a fantastic place and how much of a
challenge is it for the local community
here as we talk about the customer in
crisis inflation i'm sure you saw
yesterday went up to nine percent it's
tough wiganers are proud but it's tough
to get by yeah 100 100 and you you know
you hear people feeling in their pinches
every day
um
wigan's obviously a very working class
town um
proud people and uh yeah you you hear
stories of people like i would use food
banks and things like that and it's um
yes
it's it's about very much sign of the
times i think what one one thing we do
is we support kind of
the local brick charity which is um
we went there yesterday yeah all right
and yes it's a real good time we've had
we've had with them and yeah you see
some and hear some stories what are
quite upsetting
yeah
it certainly is um what about the cost
of tickets so you know people is this
one of the first things that might go
very much it could do i know it means a
lot to a lot of people the rule behind
the football
and um
it's it's a big part of kind of people
working there so it's a big part of the
enjoyment factors and what what they do
outside of work so
yeah for people to have to make a
decision not to come to games or
kind of miss games people who like to go
to weight games to not be able to have
the opportunity to do that it's tough
yeah good to talk to you yes you too
thanks very much indeed for joining us
really can i go chat to some of the
girls is that okay thanks a lot thanks a
lot
hi ladies
rachel and georgia
you are
rachel hi so tommy you play for the
ladies team yeah
both of you yeah yeah okay talk to me in
a bit more detail about
the kicks can i get you something we can
just see and the camera's just here so
if you just turn around then we can see
your beautiful faces ladies thank you so
tell me what positions you play and and
how important it is both to you and to
your family to be playing for wigan
warriors the ladies are still
co-warriors yeah yeah brilliant yeah um
athletic center um or half back and i'm
just injured at the moment so i'm not
glad yet this season what entry have you
got um
oh my son had that done that's horrible
isn't it
wow you're okay now though yeah yeah
slowly does it yeah a lot of bike work
yeah yeah a lot of rehab
but yeah he's good and obviously i'm
from wigan so it's a massive honor to
play for the club okay yeah and i play
wing or center at the minute i'm playing
full back um i'm not originally from
wigan but i can tell yeah
about rugby league has been at wigan so
yeah my family have now got this
connection with wigan and their massive
supporters and watch all the men's games
and watch us and they love every minute
of it okay and um are
the men very supportive of the ladies
team yeah definitely i think they are
they come and ask us questions about
training not afraid to come and say
hello to us when we're here and
they're really interested in what we do
yeah and what are the lads say when
you're out inviting we're going and you
say oh yeah i play for work and warriors
with us we're like okay we're not taking
you long
yeah
over here not corny at all um how often
do you have to try
once a week yeah so we train we train
twice a week with the women's team and
then we play on it on a sunday lovely
good to talk to you ladies thank you
i'll let you carry on training and
hopefully you're back on the pitch soon
enough thank you thank you thank you
let's just um
move this way should we and as you can
see some of the young academy guys are
still um training um over there watch
this cable as you go adam and we will be
chatting to them a bit later on when
when the first team come in as well and
also be they also have a fantastic
disabled uh section to the community and
the club as well and we'll have more on
that
wigan apart from being known for wigan
warriors is also known for its pies
we're called pie eaters we're better
than to send inzy to a pie shop hi indie
good morning
monica couldn't leave wigan without
going to a bakery and the most famous
bakery in wigan the muffin man do you
know the muffin man i know the muffin
man we're here at the muffin man bakery
we're going to chat to two of the
hardest working uh people that i've seen
on our trip so far and let's take you to
neil firstly you who's been working
incredibly hard this morning um uh neil
we're here talking about the cost of
living crisis but firstly i just want to
talk to you a bit about the work you've
been putting in this morning what time
did you get in what have you been up to
uh we got up about quarter past one this
morning
uh myself my wife we drive to the other
shop at chevington
soon my wife gets out there sort out the
pit some paperwork then i come down here
use the
half two
and then we
meet later in the afternoon and you've
been getting rolled putting rolls in
getting rolls out
how many drinking you you'll be making
today how many bits of bread you'll be
making i think today it's probably about
three thousand three three and a half
thousand bedrolls
we're gonna we'll be going out today
and then we've got all the pies that the
lads are making in the back as you've
seen before and a lot of pies as well
guys yeah yeah and what's your
speciality here i think you you recently
made a new one as well yeah we made a
steak in el pie that we
i was buying the ale from the
wholesalers and then i saw the wiley fox
brewery up in martha mill and i went to
speak to them there and they were really
helpful and they said yeah they'll
supply us with a stout
for the pie
so we don't we made that and then the
lady owns the
brewery wranglers this week saying this
stout is coming to an end so next week
or the week after i think we're going on
to a different tale
with her recommendations neil this is a
a family business three generations you
guys have been here for 35 years just
tell us what life has been like over the
last few months as a wigan business
the biggest thing we've had is buying
things into the costs uh that flower's
gone up like 30 percent in
uh well it's getting all the stock as
well
up to about two months ago we had
massive problems with foils for the pies
you know we put the pies in uh and we
covered with strudel we had to swap the
butt pies going in the foils because we
didn't have the correct foils in and we
noticed a massive increase in their
prices
and it's going to get worse you know the
governor of the bank of england is quite
right on what he said
you know we're we've been told by july
of this year
sugar alone is going to go up 60 percent
you know and
everything is moving eggs there's a
shortage of milk i read this morning uh
the day with producer arla they're
saying there's going to be a short is
massive and it it's not that long ago
they were poor they found poor farmers
with pouring milk down the drain it
sounds like a worry for you with the
times ahead um we're going to chat to
the real boss now and we'll let you
carry on i don't want any of the bread
to burn so let you keep an eye on that
and we'll swing around to sue the real
boss over here i believe you're up early
as well working away in in one of the
other stores and just tell us what
life's been like um
for you and working in the shop and
seeing the cost of living crisis deepen
particularly in an area like wigan
uh yeah it's it's it's been really hard
the prices hasn't made a massive
difference but the shortages have been
more difficult
raspberry jam for example uh is out of
stock at our wholesalers at the minute
you can't do a jam and cream ice
sandwich cake without the jam you
couldn't do that no um so we've had to
sort it elsewhere which is virtually
triple the price
um in terms of the customers what what
have people been saying to you when they
come through the doors you've had to
adjust your prices a bit what people
said you do get a little bit of moaning
but uh in general everyone's
experiencing the same thing aren't we so
people might not like to pay more but
they all know that it's it's just
it's everywhere isn't it across the
world wherever you go what's the
favorite thing you do here is it a pie
or or is it something sweet well i do
all the sweet stuff where i am so
brownies that's one of the really
popular things yeah sweet stuff made by
a sweet person so thank you so much
indeed two hard-working people at the
muffin man bakery but of course just
like everyone else they too are worried
about the future the rising prices
mean it could be a struggle for this
business as well
okay in zee for now make sure you bring
me one of those pies back please uh
meantime the cbi business body has
called on the government to step in and
take action to help struggling
households the cbi's chief economist
that's newton smith is with us now hi
rayne thanks for joining us on the
program this morning i hope you don't
mind me using your first name can you
tell me what the cbi is laying out today
yeah look i think as we've just seen on
on this program it's really tough uh for
households uh at the moment and for
businesses as well we're seeing
inflation at nine percent for households
and
across the manufacturing sector just
that rising cost of inputs has been
reaching 20
in recent months and so we know we've
got a really tough year
ahead and i think what we want to see is
some really targeted help for the most
vulnerable in society it's just not
acceptable we have a situation where
half a million households in the uk are
having to choose between heating their
homes or or putting food on the table so
we do need to see some targeted uh
support for the very poorest and most
vulnerable in our society but more
importantly the way of seeing increasing
standard of living over time is to
really keep
investment flowing in our economy help
those small businesses be able to invest
in people to keep people uh in jobs and
so for that we need the chancellor to
set out
the best uh incentives we can on capital
allowances he's been prepared to be bold
in the past but we do need to see some
more targeted action at low-income
households
and importantly extending the loan
schemes that are available for small
businesses
to make it through
this year which we know is also going to
be very tough for businesses
what about the small business scene uh
we've been chatting to a lot of small
businesses uh business owners here in
we're gonna over the last few days i
don't know if you've managed to catch
any of our our coverage and
they are really struggling many of them
are on the brink of collapse what
support can be offered to them
well during the pandemic we had a
really ambitious loan scheme and that's
still in place we have the recovery loan
scheme but we need that scheme to be
extended to the end of the year i mean
as as we heard from that muffin man
bakery if you look at the cost that
they're facing and what they see coming
down the track we know that this is
about fuel but it's also about the cost
of food about the inputs uh into those
small businesses so they need to be able
to reach for a loan scheme and keep that
in place till the end of the year uh to
help them through what will be a really
tough time we know small businesses are
really
important source of jobs in in local
communities so it's really important
that we keep them going and that we make
it easy
for them to keep
investing and that's about the
incentives we put in place
for investment it's providing some of
that targeted support to low-income
households and it's about having these
mechanisms in place where smaller
businesses uh can reach for when times
get tough
is it the cbi's view that we're heading
towards recession
whether we see a recession or just a few
quarters or hopefully not much longer
than that of really uh weak growth i
think that is absolutely on the cards
with inflation
at the levels we're seeing right now we
know that that is already starting to
slow growth in our economy
and what we need to do is to learn the
lessons from previous recessions we're
fortunate coming into this that
unemployment is is really low so we need
to keep people uh in jobs but we really
need to make sure that businesses keep
investing in people in skills we need a
more flexible system around how we help
businesses invest in training the
chancellor has promised that but we we
need to see firmer commitments and we
need to see that happening on capital
allowances he's been prepared to be bold
we have a super deduction which
gives 130 percent on businesses
on their capital investment but that
comes to an end next year and at the
same time corporation taxes going up to
25
we really need to see a successor
announce now to that capital uh
allowance a permanent deduction at 100
so those businesses out there can keep
investing and keep people in jobs um and
so that whatever we see coming down the
track it's short-lived and we see growth
and productivity and living standards
rising again
okay so just to clarify what needs to
happen for us not to fall into recession
i think we need to see some more
targeted action from the chancellor now
to really help low-income households
we don't need i don't think we're in the
state where we need to see the massive
injections of cash that we saw during
the the pandemic part of the reason for
that is if we saw that really big
stimulus to aggregate demand right now
it would just make inflation worse as we
saw uh from some that muffin producer
it's really hard to get supply and if
supply can keep up with that strong
demand will make some of these
inflationary pressures worse so it
really is about targeted spending uh for
those who are really suffering
and then that focus on the long term on
investment and training
for the long term that's how we'll get
the right
balance between demand and supply and
avoid
inflation spiking again and some of the
crisis we're facing in so many
households across the country at the
moment
before i let you go this was something
that happened at your conference just a
few months ago let me remind my viewers
the true driver of growth
is is not government it is the it is the
energy
and uh
and
dynamism and originality
of the private sector and tony yesterday
i went uh as as we all must
uh uh
to to peppa pig world and have you been
to peppa pig world who's been depends
i've been always been to pep a big world
me uh but i'm not the prime minister um
references to peppa pig
the way that the prime minister um
[Music]
dealt with peppa pig and making engine
noises at your conference is he
absolutely the right person to lead us
as far as small business and
medium-sized businesses are
concerned look i i'm not going to
comment on that i haven't had the good
fortune of being at peppa pig world i
have to say my daughters would be much
more uh interested in seeing the wig and
ladies play they're a much
bigger fan of uh women's football i
think what the what the prime minister
at that time was trying to articulate
maybe he didn't do the best job of
articulating it is just that what we
need to see in our economy is some of
the investment in creative industries we
are so successful in some of the tv
programs we export around the world in
higher education uh in uh when you think
about the medicines the vaccines we've
developed uh in the world it's really
important that we keep investment
flowing so we can create jobs in all of
our communities whether that's jobs at
our local foot football club and local
bakeries uh or larger businesses that
are exporting around the world
okay you're good rain you're very good
pivoting that one thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
thank you
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning last day of wigan with
hospitality industries still reeling
from the impact of the pandemic i'm
going to be speaking to wigan's longest
licensee about how the industry will
deal with the cost of living crisis
just after eight joined here by the mp
for wigan and shadow leveling up
secretary that's lisa namdi
[Music]
but before that some other news um here
on the programme and two more russian
soldiers will face a hearing in ukraine
for war crimes later on today the first
russian soldier to be tried for war
crimes in the conflict went on trial in
kiev yesterday meanwhile more ukrainian
soldiers have been evacuated from the
besieged as of style steel works in
mariopol they were travelling on buses
tracked all the way by russian armoured
vehicles some of the fighters who
emerged were seen accompanied by
moscow-backed separatists
russia is threatening to put them on
trial for war crimes
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky says russia has now turned to
laser weapons because of a lack of
missiles
the largest
ever free well-being program in uh
secondary schools is being launched
today it's aimed at tackling worrying
trends in teenage suicide rates
maddie standing by for us hi maddie tell
us more
hi kay yes so from today secondary
school school pupils at um state schools
will be offered free mental health
checks um to tackle something like you
said there's really worrying mental
health trends in young people suicide
rates have gone up at 45 percent over
the last 10 years so this is a way
hopefully of of early identification of
problems which is so key in treating
them and i'm joined uh now by the uh
with sorry i'm joined with uh now with
the founder of the program richard can
you tell us why you uh launched this and
what you're hoping to achieve with it
yeah thank you and govox was founded
back in 2018 following the sad loss of a
number of young people to suicide and
really with the mission to make sure
that people that need support are
connected effectively and efficiently to
the brilliant support that's available
so over the last four years that's that
platform's growing massively and it's
got to the point where we're able to
roll out to schools for free in the uk
because
75 percent of mental health problems in
adults are actually started when they're
when they're young
so working on the principle that the
sooner we can catch those students and
focus on their happiness engagement and
connectivity
then the better and healthier society
will be moving forward thank you and so
from today secondary schools can sign up
to this program which will hopefully go
live from september
okay maddie thank you now it was a night
of heartbreak for rangers fans in
seville as their team fell agonizingly
short in the europa league final losing
on penalties tom is there for us this
morning hi tom
yeah they spent every ounce of energy
both the players and the fans here in
seville last night and it just wasn't to
be they went toe to toe with a very good
eintracht frankfurt side but rangers as
you say lost on penalties the story of
the night well
rangers forward joe arribo put them
ahead in the second half and that sent
the rangers fans who are here on mass
into complete raptures but within 10
minutes or so the germans were back
level with their colombian forward
raphael borre who got himself between
the rangers defense and threw on goal
and drew things level and sent it to the
very last kicks of this competition it
was penalties again and german
efficiency that just had the edge over
glaswegian graft the full guy was aaron
ramsey the welsh international he missed
his penalty there were big fears that
this would descend into violence in
seville last night but there was nothing
it was
very few isolated incidents and ranges
emerged from this adventure with a great
deal of credit
okay for now thank you
also making news for the legal teams for
colleen rooney and rebecca vardy will
deliver their closing arguments today as
the multi-million pound libel trial
comes to an end ms rooney is being sued
for defamation by ms bhardi after
accusing her of leaking private stories
to the media which mizbadi denies a
judgment is expected at a later date
and on the latest leg of their royal
tour in canada prince charles and
camilla have been urged to face up to
britain's colonial past and its
treatment of indigenous people despite
being met with cheering crowds they've
also been met with protests against the
visit
obviously more on that throughout the
course of the day here on sky news uh
but we've been here in wigan for four
days now we've been to all sorts of
places um just to take the temperature
really of how the uh people in this good
time my hometown um feel about the cost
of living crisis as you can see today hi
guys morning morning morning morning we
are they're quite a lot they're not this
quiet when they're on the field trust me
um we're at the um wigan warriors
training ground just watch that adam as
you go by um and we'll be hearing from
the first team a little bit later on
they have got a game on saturday and
then a big game the following saturday
tell me more about that but also we went
to beach hill primary school which was
my
old school it's been significantly
rebuilt since i was first there but it
was great to spend some time
with the kids they would the teachers
tell them afterwards that i used to go
to the school and then they contacted us
yesterday to say that they've been doing
some projects about
sky and
beach hill more generally etc so what we
thought we'd do is big reveal we thought
we'd invite them by hello come in come
in come here come here come in come here
come in come in and here they all are
hello coming in coming in hi teacher hi
teachers coming in let's go over this
way guys let's go over here and then
there's room for everybody here we go
about here tell me what you've got
all this way facing this camera guys
around me come quick as you can that's
the way here we go here we go here we go
tell me what you've got
a picture of me how good is i wish my
hair was that lovely thank you
let me look at yours as well who are you
i'm kidding
oh yeah i remember you and you are
freddie i like that freddy as well have
we got another one who's this
amelia i remember you as well i remember
your lovely hair who else have we got
here emilia robin lydia chris connor
excellent so
tell me guys about coming a bit a little
bit closer and then we can see you all
maybe come a little bit closer just
coming in amelia at the end so and then
we can hear you on our microphone so
tell me how you felt about sky coming to
your school for the day i felt really
excited excited yeah was it that or was
it the fact that krusty the pie came
along a bit later on
yeah i know i know i know that's me
putting in my place and what about you
what did you enjoy about us coming to
see you are you a prefect didn't you oh
head boy oh i say come on tell me so
the best thing was that and you got come
around and everyone got a chance to him
speak up and have the turn of um
speaking and
yeah so everyone got the chance to do
something yeah everybody had a chance to
say something who else wants to chat to
us
chris where's chris
there he is come on chris squeezing in
ladies there we go chris
um i felt excited about it did you
happen did you yeah what made you happy
about it uh though it was just an
opportunity to like
um
someone to come in to a
school and do something fun yeah anybody
else wants to chat to us yep young man
what's your name uh freddie freddie come
on it was just interesting because you
don't just have a regular day at school
and then just at the end of the day here
there's a news station coming over it
was it was interesting and kind of neat
just to think about what was going to
happen and then the day came and it was
just fun excellent who else does anybody
else want to have anything to say before
i let you all go at the end yeah who's
you what's your name finn finn i love
your hair finn god it was
it was interesting to see how the um
it's felt how the news is filmed yeah
because you don't know what's going on
behind the scenes do you i don't know if
adam can show uh what happens behind the
scenes so we can see some of the other
camera work that's going on at the
moment because people don't always see
that side of things do they any of you
want to go into telly
you all want to go into yeah i want to
go into telly
yep
say again football so basically i'm
telling you exactly thank you so much
for coming guys i really appreciate it
uh you've got to go back to class now
sorry about that maybe we'll come and
see you again next year how does that
sound yeah
well let's see let's see oh okay well
wherever you're going i'll come and find
you how does that sound it's lovely to
see you guys i'm gonna have to carry on
with the show as they say but it's
lovely to see you i know that we've got
transport to get you back to school
sorry thank you for coming nice to see
you
we'll talk to you soon thanks a lot well
joining me now um is hept athlete for
wigan harrier's danielle mcgifford and i
think she's this way so let's go and
find her should we
hi danielle i hopefully you're through
here there she is hi how are you
nice to see you we're in harriers yes
tell me more
yeah kept talking about your kittens
because it's a little tank top
we can walk that way as we're going i've
been here for 15 years now have you okay
what are your uh what's your disciplines
um
oh wow
now that is properly hard stuff yeah
yeah i don't know if you can see this
but the viewers at home can see there's
a picture of me with my sister when we
were um
training for wigan harriers uh yeah we
did really really well it has to be said
i was 100 200 first leg of the relay and
the javelin and my sister was 800 and
1500.
yeah so it's
although wigan warriors and wigan
athletic are a big deal here in the time
working harriers are too yeah and we
have some big stars haven't you oh
definitely we've had many olympians past
few in a few years we are doing harry
koffel emily bothwick obviously had
jenny meadows and like there's more in
the past as well so we're a great club
great history how important is it for
kids to get involved with sport
massively i mean athletics especially
like our fans like the fundamental sport
to be honest if you want to go into
rugby if you want to go to football you
have to be able to run yeah so i think
it's really important that kids from
really young gauge get involved with
athletics and use the fundamentals of
running jumping and throwing
okay and what would you say to those who
suggest that you know what um i i can't
run it's just too hard
i'd rather watch it on the telly
everyone can run can they everyone can
run yeah okay
how do you start
there's all sorts of ways is that that
couch to fight yeah exactly so there's a
couch to 5k there's just getting out for
a walk we get up for a walk he then
thinks you know maybe i could get out
for a run for a little bit and i think
everyone can start somewhere it's
definitely something accessible to
everyone and i think that was seen in
lockdown as well yeah i think you found
far more people on the roads running and
things like that and i think the part
the pack runs and everything yeah
they've like increased massively over
the past few years with him obviously
covered and everyone decided to go out
for a run yeah okay i've broken my foot
otherwise i'd give you a raise i
wouldn't i don't need to see you it's
exciting you've got to rush off go on
give it a good run there you go
how impressive hept athlete how good is
that well hundreds of wiganers and and
prisoners have been helped into
long-term employment here in the town
they've been um guaranteed jobs it has
to be say as part of a housing project
and the company behind it has even
received royal recognition to tell us
more about it john ceo of procure plus
holdings and that is uh mike uh brogan
hi mike thanks for joining us on the
program this morning tell me more
good morning kay
yes we started off our factory in wigan
in hindley hmp hindley probably about
five years ago now
but the story of our businesses goes
back further that's about 15 20 years
and it's all about uh improving the life
chances of people interested in the
education guy you had on before saying a
similar thing
and it's a matter of trying to get at
people at an early stage obviously by
the time they're in hindi it's a little
bit too late for that but that's not to
say that we can't do something about it
and get people back on track
and that's what it's about really our
business is very much
around working with housing associations
local authorities
we pretty much uh help them do their
capital improvements we buy stuff for
them sell it back to them and then we
make a margin and put that money
back into the communities where the work
was going on and wigan is one of our big
customers so we do a lot of work in
working youth zone and indeed hindu
prison
uh mike
we were chatting to a youngster uh
yesterday young guy yesterday and he was
telling me that uh he
in these tough times he's really
concerned
uh about kids turning to um street crime
and gang crime uh
how concerned are you about that what
can we do about it
very concerned about it and one of the
things we found when we went into wigan
and in other prisons we work with lots
of prisons
uh is that nobody there
wants to be there you know you can't get
an eight-year-old imagining that's where
i want to be when i'm 23. it just
doesn't happen
but it does happen unfortunately you
know it doesn't happen in there but i'm
in reality so we do need to do something
about it and it's all around equality of
opportunity and trying to do the
prevention so the moment we're catching
people when they've been through the
system and uh
we're trying to help them when we do
help them actually move on and get a job
it's sad that sixty percent of the
people that leave prison end up back
within a matter of months
on our arrangements the factory we have
it's down to six percent so it's
obviously a huge reduction
without dealing with things leave it
there i'm sorry because we're out of
time but it's really good to talk to you
this morning thank you very much for
joining us on the program thank you
thanks a lot coming up in the next hour
of the program we'll be bringing you
more from here at uh the robin park
arena and the training stadium and i
don't know if you can just whiz that way
really quickly adam to show the kids are
enjoying their day here as part of the
community
[Music]